hey guys it is Friday oh what a week I'm
so glad it's the weekend and I can
finally relax yeah I feel like it's
probably not gonna happen because III
starts tomorrow but before we bring you
all the news and features from that
let's talk about the week that was
here's our top 5 stories hang on I
bought pool inflatables today did I make
mistake big changes are coming to call
of duty this year that's right the
series mainstay creator class is being
replaced in Call of Duty World War 2
with a new feature called divisions in a
playstation blog post sledgehammer games
head Glenn Schofield explained the
changes as part of the new division
system rather than just customizing your
weapons loadout and player appearance
you can select one of five different
iconic World War two divisions that each
have different combat training division
training and weapon skills it sounds a
little like black ops 3 s operators the
blog post goes on to talk about the new
multiplayer mode called war mode which
will be an asymmetric narrative driven
battle between teams playing as axis and
Allied forces called GD World War 2 will
be showing off at e3 next week so make
sure you're subscribed so you don't miss
any of the coverage Tekken 7 players can
breathe a sigh of relief today as the
game has been patched that means I'm
finally gonna be good at it right
probably not nor the patch applies to
the ps4 version and will address issues
with the game's online matchmaking more
specifically it's intended to improve
stability and establish connections with
other online players more consistently
the game will also no longer share a
player's character title rank and wins
before a match kicks off thanks to the
new changes if you're tired of having
your mom insulted by Internet strangers
the patch also lets you toggle voice
chat on and off and it set off by
default a similar patch will arrive for
the game's Xbox one and PC versions next
week while we're on the topic of
fighting games injustice 2 is getting a
new character now I'm good at this one I
don't know after a week of teasers
NetherRealm announced that Red Hood is
coming to injustice 2 on June 13 Red
Hood is the gun toting antihero who
tried to clean up Gotham City not the
one with a picnic basket heading to
Grandma's place no he'll be available
for owners of the deluxe edition or
those that have picked up the fighter
pack 1 the fighter pack 1 also gets you
Starfire and Mortal Kombat's sub-zero
for 20 bucks while the $100 deluxe
edition gets you access to all
nine upcoming fighters we're just a day
away from EAS e3 presa and the company
have released a bunch of information
letting us know what we're in for
ea confirmed they have at least eight
games to talk about - which are
seemingly yet to be announced as for
what we do know I'll list the mothball
Dan gives you a Hut take about how he
feels about seizing them at the show
Star Wars Battlefront - lady imperial
elite soldier single-player and die
sound design yes please
FIFA 18 I don't know what that is Madden
NFL 18 I got Madden with my Vita when I
bought it and I just assumed I'll be
able to pick up the rules as I played I
was very very wrong NBA Live 18 if I
were to play a sports game it would
probably be this but as it stands I only
know LeBron James through Judd Apatow
movies need for speed pay back a cartel
name the house in a place called Fortune
City if this has a bin diesel cameo my
head will explode battlefield what so
keen to hear about the in the name of
the SAR DLC lady soldiers new behemoth
new maps new weapons yes please yes
press conference kicks off at 12 p.m. Pt
tomorrow so join us then to find out
exactly what's in store Ubisoft have had
a really hard time giving a little
misuse Assassin's Creed they have first
off we've got an off screen picture of a
guy on a boat and then we got a t-shirt
which seemingly leaked the protagonists
name and now target have accidentally
released a pre-order card which appears
to show even more information the
pre-order card was posted to neogaf by
user ex-pilot protagonist and shows a
very assassin's creed looking character
approaching a pyramid this seemingly
confirms the long room is setting off
egypt i mean that's even the sphinx
there's also mention of a pre-order
bonus mission called secrets of the
first pyramid really the only surprise
here would be if it's somehow not egypt
i don't know I'm still hoping this is an
Indiana Jones tie-in the pre-order card
also seemingly confirms what we've one
suspected that the game will be called
Assassin's Creed origins the card also
alludes to a gold edition the net you
the season pass deluxe pack and
steelbook case let me know in the
comments if you actually use steel
bookcases nuts GameSpot news for today
and the next time you see us we will be
at e3 see it all the biggest breaking
news coming out of e3 be sure to pick up
the game spot now app which is totally
free on iOS and Android we will see you
guys there see ya
alright now I'm taking this off how do I
do that yeah is there like a release are
you close your favorite yeah you're
sweating oh ha ha ha ah let me take
these glasses ah
no yeah alright here we go
ok it's ok you can do it al what is it
inside I want to be inside that seems
like a like a design for Oh huh oh my
god
it was a bun in time I know what you
guys worried about just abundance